Regarde où tu marches, putain.
Espèce de taré.
Sale con.
J'ai failli l'écraser, ce con.
Unité 5, on est en route.
On y sera dans 3 min.
Non !
C'est là.
C'est où, la fête ?
- Tu peux ouvrir la porte ?
- Non.
Vas-y, défonce la porte.
Tout va bien, on est là.
Il va mourir.
- Non, on est là maintenant.
- Il va mourir.
- Comment tu t'appelles ?
- Karina.
- Salut, Karina.
- Tout va bien, Karina.
- Environ 15 ans ?
- Quinze.
Le travail a commencé.
Le pouls est fort et régulier.
- T'en dis quoi ?
- Elle va accoucher.
Ça va aller, Karina.
- Batman.
- Comment, mon chéri ?
- Ce n'est pas Batman, chéri.
Je vais chercher du secours.
Batman.
Tu y es presque.
Pousse, Karina.
Continue à pousser.
Arrête de pousser.
Le cordon est autour du cou.
Il s'est enroulé deux fois.
C'est pas vrai.
Monsieur ?
Je ne sais pas
ce que je suis censée faire.
Marcus.
- Donnez-moi la main.
- Je ne peux pas.
C'est bon, je l'ai.
Pousse.
L'enseigne ne va pas tenir.
J'ai peur.
Merde.
Je vois sa tête, il arrive.
Donnez-moi la main.
Il est là, tu y es presque.
Maintenant.
Vas-y, continue à pousser.
Il est là, il arrive.
Batman.
Il respire.
- Combien de temps sans oxygène ?
- Environ 2 min.
On va l'examiner.
Marcus, t'es de service ?
On a une agression au couteau.
Laisse la paperasserie à Jen.
J'ai pigé.
Comme ça, t'es encore papa.
T'en es à combien ?
Cinq, en comptant celui-là.
Elle va lui donner ton prénom ?
C'est le démon.
Qu'est-ce qu'on a ?
Vous devez l'emmener à l'hôpital.
Elle fait une hémorragie.
Elle a dû recevoir
environ cinq coups de couteau.
- Quel genre ?
- Un couteau de boucher.
Femme de 20 ans
poignardée à l'abdomen.
Préparez du O négatif.
Je connais cette fille.
- Comment elle s'appelle ?
- Emma.
Emma, tu m'entends ?
On est là pour t'aider.
Tu dois nous aider, toi aussi.
Ça fait mal,
mais tu dois rester éveillée.
Tu peux faire ça ?
Tu ne dois pas t'endormir.
Faut y aller.
On est bientôt arrivés.
Tu veux savoir mon nom ?
Je m'appelle Marcus.
Marcus.
C'est ça, Marcus.
Je t'aime.
- Dépêche-toi, Shawn.
- On arrive.
Shawn.
Elle a perdu connaissance.
- On s'en occupe.
- Elle parlait, il y a 3 min.
C'est bon, on s'en occupe.
- Où est Marcus ?
- Trauma 4.
Un taré s'est mis à jouer
à Jack l'éventreur.
Bats-toi, Emma.
Marcus connaît la fille.
- Tu déconnes ?
- Non.
Défibrillateur.
On choque.
Massage cardiaque.
Allez.
- Ça va ?
- Elle va s'en sortir.
On choque.
Allez.
Massage cardiaque.
On recommence.
Elle va s'en sortir.
On choque.
Allez.
Non.
Elle est morte.
Heure du décès, 23 h 55.
Marcus, je suis désolée.
Non...
Non.
Qu'est-ce que tu fous ?
Éloigne-toi d'elle.
Ne vous approchez pas.
Marcus.
Marcus, ne fais pas ça.
Marcus, arrête ça.
- Marcus.
- Elle est morte.
T'as perdu la tête.
Elle est morte.
Appelez la sécurité.
Bats-toi.
Allez, réveille-toi.
T'es devenu fou.
Tu veux finir en prison ?
Elle n'est pas morte.
Marcus, éloigne-toi d'elle.
Arrête, elle est morte.
Allez.
C'est quoi ce bordel ?
Emma, non.
Lâchez-moi, elle n'est pas morte.
Emma.
Non.
Emma, non.
Non, Emma.
- J'ai un truc pour toi.
- C'est quoi ?
Ouvre-le.
- C'est magnifique.
- Tu es si belle.
- Elle était morte.
- Je devrais le faire arrêter.
Il est déjà sur la sellette.
C'était pas de sa faute,
vous le savez.
Il connaissait cette fille.
On vous revaudra ça.
Vous avez intérêt
à vous tenir à carreau.
Vous m'avez compris ?
- Vous m'avez entendu ?
- Oui.
Cette affaire n'en restera pas là.
M. Lathrop, une patiente a disparu.
Elle était inconsciente,
il y a 5 min.
Ce genre de conduite
est totalement inacceptable.
Vous le surveillez.
S'il récidive,
vous serez tenus pour responsables.
Tu la connaissais, hein ?
T'as dû la croiser à l'épicerie.
C'est comme si je la
connaissais depuis toujours.
- J'ai senti un truc spécial.
- Réincarnation.
- Tu l'as connue dans une autre vie.
- Ouais, c'est ça.
Dis pas ça, t'en sais rien.
L'univers,
c'est un truc complètement fou.
Non...
Je la connaissais.
Ça restera un mystère.
Tu ne viens pas boire une bière ?
- J'ai besoin de faire le vide.
- Jen sera là.
Jen sera là.
Je rentre retrouver ma femme.
Ne retourne pas à l'hôpital,
sinon Lathrop te coupera les burnes.
Il les vendra sur le marché noir.
Le marché noir se fout
de tes couilles de Mexicain.
- Marcus.
- Merde.
Vite, pousse-toi.
Dépêche-toi.
Merde.
Je suis désolée.
Je suis vraiment désolée.
J'aurais dû la sauver.
Elle a été poignardée six fois.
Ç'aurait été un légume
si t'avais réussi à la sauver.
Ça te dérange si je reste ?
Je m'en fous.
Je vais dans l'autre salle.
Tu ne vas pas devenir
comme ton ancien collègue, hein ?
Martineau, il traînait souvent ici.
Il s'asseyait près des cadavres.
Il leur parlait même parfois.
- Je ne suis pas comme Martineau.
- Tant mieux.
Ce mec était siphonné.
C'était trop tard, mon vieux.
Elle était morte avant que t'arrives.
Mlle Markham n'avait pas sur elle
sa carte médicale
attestant qu'elle souffrait de diabète.
La présence d'héroïne sur les lieux
justifie la décision de M. Galan
de lui administrer du Narcan.
La présence de bouteilles d'alcool
a conduit M. Galan à présumer que
la léthargie de Mlle Markhan
était due à une intoxication
et non à un choc diabétique.
- Comment tu t'appelles ?
- Angel.
Il est également noté que la patiente
ne répondant pas au Narcan,
M. Galan a ensuite établi
un diagnostic correct,
mais ses efforts pour la réanimer
ont été infructueux.
Bien que l'on soit convaincus
que M. Galan sera déchargé
des récriminations pesant contre lui,
nous préférons,
dans l'intérêt de notre compagnie,
nous prononcer
à l'égard de cet incident
qu'une fois que l'enquête
sera terminée.
La mise à pied de M. Galan
nous semble une mesure prudente.
Sans solde.
Enfoirés.
Si l'enquête déclare qu'il n'a commis
aucune faute professionnelle,
il recevra les salaires non perçus
lors de sa suspension.
M. Galan, comprenez-vous
la mesure que nous avons prise ?
M. Galan,
comprenez-vous
la mesure que nous avons prise ?
Oui.
Des questions ?
Non.
Ce conseil de discipline
est ajourné jusqu'au 14 octobre.
- C'est n'importe quoi.
- Ouais, faut que tu te rebelles.
Tu te crois en mai 68 ?
Faut leur rentrer dans le lard.
Ouais, emmerde-les.
On pourrait se voir un film demain.
Je préparerai le dîner.
À demain.
C'est terminé, je te le jure.
Marcus, je suis une idiote.
On n'a pas d'enfants
et très peu de bien en commun.
Je ne veux pas divorcer.
Je ne veux pas être cocu.
Je vais prendre un avocat,
tout ça me dépasse.
Je ne sais pas quoi faire.
Moi non plus.
Salut, papa.
Tu veux que je ferme en sortant ?
Ouais, merci.
Ça va ?
Ouais, ça va.
Bon week-end, papa.
D'accord, toi aussi.
- Merci.
- De rien.
Mon Père ?
Un beau jour, elle est arrivée
et a pris un balai.
Elle était trop jeune, je lui ai dit.
Mais elle continuait.
Elle en avait marre des gamineries
des autres filles de l'église.
Elle était décidée
à devenir une vraie chrétienne.
Petite Fleur.
Pardon ?
Elle me fait penser à Sainte Thérèse.
Je ne vais pas beaucoup à la messe.
Thérèse est morte jeune, elle aussi.
Emma était aussi pure et chaste
que n'importe quelle sainte.
Notre Dieu est cruel, à mon sens.
Comment peut-il tolérer
une telle violence ?
Papa, t'es flic ?
- Non.
- Une petite pipe ?
C'est 50 $.
- Un autre jour peut-être.
- Ce sera peut-être trop tard.
Pas aujourd'hui.
Désolée.
Je vous ai fait peur ?
Vous auriez cinq minutes ?
Je n'en aurai pas pour longtemps.
En quoi puis-je vous aider ?
- Pardon, vous êtes madame...
- Appelez-moi Lilith.
Très bien.
Désolé, il est interdit de fumer.
Qui fume ?
Les flics ont tout passé
au peigne fin.
Si personne ne réclame ses affaires,
je jette son merdier dehors.
J'ignore d'où elle venait.
Une nuit, elle est arrivée ici
et a imposé sa loi.
Une vraie salope,
si vous voulez mon avis.
Vous ne croyez pas au surnaturel,
M. Carruthers ?
Détachez-moi.
Vous avez fait
comme si je n'existais pas.
Détachez-moi.
Vous m'avez compliqué la vie.
Allez, détachez-moi.
C'est facile de se glisser
dans un corps quelques secondes.
Juste pour s'amuser.
Détachez-moi.
Trouver un corps libre,
c'est plus dur.
- Il y a beaucoup de concurrence.
- Qui êtes-vous ?
Regardez-les.
Vos bébés sont fiers de vous ?
Ma famille ne vous a rien fait.
Ils ignorent ce que papa a fait.
Laissez ma famille tranquille.
Vous avez fait des tas
de sacrifices pour votre famille,
je me trompe, M. Carruthers ?
Il vous en reste un dernier à faire.
Vous jouez avec le feu, Vic.
Il y a une chose qu'il faut
que je vous dise.
Je gagne toujours.
Vous êtes sûr de pas être flic ?
Certain.
Vous étiez flic avant, hein ?
Elle se livrait à des trucs bizarres.
Des trucs surnaturels.
La sorcellerie, le satanisme.
Vous voyez la pute au grand c ur
style Pretty Woman ?
C'était pas elle.
Son c ur était plus dur
que de la pierre.
Vous faites quoi ?
Qu'est-ce que vous voulez ?
Putain, vous voulez quoi ?
Vous faites quoi ?
Vous voulez quoi ?
Je veux juste une chose.
Une toute petite chose.
Une chose...
insignifiante.
Quoi ?
Votre vie.
Je peux le garder ?
Elle en aura plus besoin.
Vous avez fini ?
J'ai des trucs à faire.
Oui, bien sûr.
Toujours sceptique,
M. Carruthers ?
Il est facile de croire au diable.
Il suffit d'ouvrir les yeux.
L'enfer est tout autour de nous.
La bonté d'Emma.
J'y pense sans arrêt.
Voilà une raison de croire en Dieu.
Je me dis que si j'avais été
plus intelligent,
si j'avais été plus fort,
j'aurais pu la protéger.
Le diable existe.
Dieu ne sera pas toujours là
pour nous protéger.
Il n'a pas été là pour Emma.
C'était à nous de la protéger.
On devrait prier un peu moins
et lutter un peu plus.
Pour faire de ce monde
un lieu où Emma serait en sécurité.
Un monde qui, je crois,
n'a encore jamais existé.
Les gens appellent avant.
Je n'ai pas votre numéro.
Il est dans l'annuaire.
Je travaille de nuit.
Le jour, je dors.
Excusez-moi, madame.
Je suis désolé pour
ce qui est arrivé à Elizabeth.
Selon le rapport de police,
vous avez refusé de l'identifier.
Je refusais de voir ma fille.
Pourquoi j'aurai été la voir morte ?
Quand lui avez-vous parlé
pour la dernière fois ?
Ça doit faire quatre ans.
C'est elle qui m'a fait ça.
Quand je dormais.
On s'était disputées.
Elle hurlait qu'elle allait me tuer.
J'y ai pas fait attention.
J'imaginais pas
qu'elle le pensait vraiment.
C'est pas dans le rapport.
Elle n'a pas fait de prison.
Ils l'ont envoyée en maison de repos.
Elle en est sortie au bout d'un an.
Deux jours plus tard,
elle s'enfuyait.
Elle m'a menacée de venir terminer
ce qu'elle n'avait pas fini.
Je l'ai crue, cette fois.
L'ambulancier qui est inculpé,
on devrait lui décerner une médaille.
Ils ont peur de poursuites,
mais je n'intenterai aucun procès.
La nuit après sa mort,
j'ai dormi comme un ange.
Elle n'a pas été toujours comme ça.
Enfant, elle était adorable.
À l'âge de 15 ans,
elle est tombée très malade.
Une grosse fièvre.
Son c ur s'est même arrêté.
Quand ils l'ont réanimée,
c'était plus la même.
Elle était méchante.
Maussade.
Ma petite fille,
elle est morte à l'âge de 15 ans.
Cette traînée dont vous me parlez,
c'est rien pour moi.
Elle est trop jeune pour mourir.
C'est pas juste.
Excusez-moi.
C'est rien.
Je suis désolée.
On a tous envie
d'être encore près d'elle,
d'une manière ou d'une autre.
- Vous êtes un camarade de classe ?
- Non, madame.
Je l'ai connue au refuge.
Vous comprenez l'espagnol ?
Elle tenait un journal intime.
Elle écrivait tous les jours.
Son père était Argentin.
Il lui a appris l'espagnol
avant de mourir.
Chaque page de son journal
est une lettre qui lui est destinée.
Je suis incapable de les lire.
Vous voulez que je vous les lise ?
Cher Papa,
aujourd'hui, il y a eu un
tremblement de terre au Pérou.
Sur une photo, un homme tenait
son fils mort dans ses bras.
Ses jambes étaient couvertes de sang.
La souffrance pouvait se lire
sur le visage du père.
Une souffrance profonde,
de celles qui ne s'en iront jamais.
Je sais que le petit
est dans un endroit meilleur.
Je ne prierai pas pour lui ce soir.
Je prierai pour son père
et pour sa mère, où qu'elle soit.
Et pour ses frères et s urs.
Pour tous ceux qui l'aimaient
et qui souffrent tant ce soir.
- T'es complètement folle.
- Ne pars pas.
Tu t'automutiles, maintenant ?
Je t'en prie, ne pars pas.
T'as perdu la tête.
Ne t'en va pas.
Je ne t'ai connue que 20 minutes.
Mais tu es la meilleure personne
que j'ai connue.
Allô.
Marcus ?
Adieu.
Carla ?
- Jen, va vite chez moi.
- Quoi ?
- C'est Carla, vas-y.
- OK.
Vite.
- On y va. C'est Carla.
- Entendu.
Carla.
Non.
Allez, recrache ça.
Merde.
C'est bien, bébé.
C'est bien, recrache ça.
C'est bon, on est là.
Qu'est-ce qu'elle a fait ?
- Elle a avalé quoi ?
- Tout, ramène la trousse.
- On va aux urgences ?
- La trousse, vite.
Carla, tu m'entends ?
Il faut l'hospitaliser.
On va devoir faire un rapport.
Si tu les laisses m'interner
dans l'unité psychiatrique,
je recommencerais.
Je te jure que je le ferai.
Il mérite mieux que ça.
Salut, maman.
Carruthers.
C'est les empreintes de C. Kuntz.
- Caroline Kuntz, je connais pas.
- La Criminelle, non plus.
C'est une fonctionnaire.
Elle est professeur des écoles.
Elle vit à Maywood.
C'est là que ça devient étrange.
Kuntz était à une réunion scolaire
il y a deux jours.
Elle a eu une attaque.
Une ambulance est venue la chercher.
Son ECG était plat.
Elle est morte environ quatre min.
Ils l'ont réanimée.
Ils l'ont mise dans un lit.
Mais elle a disparu.
Elle a disparu ?
Elle a abattu deux employés
de sang froid
et s'en est allée
comme si de rien n'était.
- Quel est le rapport avec Vic ?
- Ça devient tordu.
Avant ces deux derniers jours,
c'était Mère Thérésa.
- John, faut que j'y aille.
- OK, merci.
Allô ?
Je feuillette l'agenda de Vic.
Il avait rendez-vous
avec le Père Vernon tous les jours.
- Tu sais pourquoi ?
- Non.
- Papa ?
- Oui.
- Tu reviens quand ?
-Très vite.
J'ai quelques histoires à régler.
D'accord.
Je crois savoir ce qu'il s'est passé.
Aidez-moi à remplir les blancs.
John, le secret de la confession
ne souffre pas d'exception.
Sa mort ne change rien.
Votre fils voulait
que je vous donne cette lettre.
Au cas où il viendrait à mourir.
Il m'a demandé de la lire.
Vous avez été engagés pour enquêter
sur la mort d'une prostituée.
Elizabeth Markham, oui.
Pour Victor,
ce n'était pas une coïncidence.
C'était Dieu qui le punissait.
Votre fils avait très peur.
Il était convaincu
d'avoir perdu son âme.
Allez, ouvre la porte.
Au cas où tu ne le saurais pas,
tu n'es plus suspendu.
Suspendu.
Tu te souviens
de la prostituée morte ?
Ça sent le renard.
Shawn, allume la lumière.
Génial.
Dès qu'Henderson a su
qu'il n'y aurait pas de poursuites,
il a décidé de
mettre fin à l'enquête.
- Génial, non ?
- T'as fait quoi à part te soûler ?
Un peu de traduction.
De la traduction.
À part ces cochonneries,
tu as mangé quelque chose ?
Génial.
Salut, Carla.
Tu te sens mieux ?
On passe juste un cap difficile.
T'es hors de la réalité.
- C'est pas tes affaires.
- D'accord.
Laisse tomber.
Un homme sait ce qu'il doit faire.
Prendre une douche, par exemple.
Va faire un brin de toilette.
Parker a démissionné,
tu peux intégrer son équipe.
Ils commencent à 15 h.
Si ça te branche.
Ça me branche.
Super.
Te voilà de retour parmi nous.
Appelle-moi si ça ne va pas.
Faut que j'y aille.
Je vais juste travailler.
Je prends mon portable.
Faut que j'y aille.
- Vous et moi, faut qu'on parle.
- On n'a rien à se dire.
Je viens d'enterrer mon fils.
Je ne suis pas d'humeur à plaisanter.
Un certain Jeff Morgan
a sauté d'un immeuble il y a 8 jours.
Il avait une famille,
un bon travail...
Aucune raison de se suicider.
Vous connaissez cet homme ?
Non.
Vous êtes sûr ?
C'était un ami de mon fils
et un de vos clients.
Votre prostituée, Lizzie Markham,
le faisait chanter.
- Il a emprunté 25 000 $ à mon fils.
- J'ai fait chanter personne.
Mon fils s'en est mêlé
quand elle a réclamé plus d'argent.
Il est retourné à la banque
retirer 20 000 $ de plus.
Voilà où ça devient intéressant.
Mon fils n'a donné l'argent
ni à son ami Jeff,
ni à Lizzie Markham.
C'est à vous qu'il l'a donné.
J'ai fait chanter personne.
Mon fils vous a payé 20 000 $
pour que vous résolviez ce problème.
Mon fils vous a engagé pour la tuer.
Vous avez fait en sorte
qu'elle ait un choc diabétique.
Vous avez perdu les pédales.
Qui a tué mon fils ?
Foutez le camp de mon établissement.
Tu perds rien pour attendre,
enfoiré.
À plus tard, papa.
Josie.
Ouais ?
Tu veux ma photo ?
- T'es la femme de quelqu'un ?
- Non, Josie.
Comment tu connais mon nom ?
Je veux...
une passe.
Je fais pas les femmes.
- Combien de temps ?
- Le temps qu'il faudra, Ray.
Rends-moi ça.
Non, laisse-moi le faire.
Écoute ça.
13 septembre.
Tous ceux de mon âge
ont déjà fait l'amour une fois.
Je me dis parfois
que je ne dois pas être normale.
C'est une tentation du diable,
je le sais.
Une fille croyante.
J'en ai envie.
L'envie est parfois insupportable.
J'ai envie de Daniel.
Elle est sortie avec lui deux fois.
Ce ne serait pas bien.
Je ne veux pas être nonne,
mais je ferai l'amour
avec le père de mes enfants.
Un sacré numéro, cette fille.
Je le trouverai,
j'en suis convaincue.
Waouh !
- C'est incroyable.
- Elle est morte.
- Jen...
- Non, écoute-moi.
C'était une fille incroyable,
mais elle est morte.
Elle est morte et enterrée,
elle ne reviendra pas.
Perso, je connais personne
qui soit revenu d'entre les morts.
J'ai l'impression de devenir fou.
Dernièrement,
tu me rappelles Martineau.
Je ne suis pas Martineau.
Je suis tombé amoureux.
Pour de vrai.
D'une fille qui est morte.
Continue, bébé.
Montre-moi comment tu fais.
Ne parle pas.
Je suis revenue pour toi,
Josie.
Ray ! Ray ! Ray !
Josie ?
Pousse-toi ! Josie ?
Josie.
Je t'ai manqué, Ray ?
Non.
T'es sûr de vouloir rentrer ?
On pourrait...
On pourrait aller chez moi.
Et ensuite ?
Jen, t'es ma meilleure amie.
Des fois, ça arrive.
Le vent est contre nous.
Il sera toujours contre nous.
Il faut se battre pour tout.
Toujours ?
Presque toujours.
Je dois y aller.
Marcus.
T'embrasses très bien.
Toi aussi.
Salut.
T'es sortie du lit, c'est bien.
Je vais enlever mon uniforme.
Carla ?
Bébé.
Non.
Shawn, elle l'a fait.
- Carla a fait une tentative.
- On arrive.
En haut.
Passe-moi le sac.
- Elle respire ?
- Non.
- Son pouls ?
- Nul.
Depuis environ 4 min.
Charge à 200.
Rien.
Charge à 300.
Toujours rien.
Charge à 360.
Allez.
Rien.
Encore une fois.
Vas-y.
Elle est morte.
Allez.
- Va préparer l'ambulance.
- J'hallucine.
Tu vas t'en sortir.
On s'occupe de toi.
Marcus.
Bébé, tu ne dois pas l'enlever.
Je...
t'aime.
Emma ?
- C'est le suicide ?
- Elle était morte, on l'a réanimée.
Vous êtes une veinarde.
- Je reste.
- Non, pas cette fois.
Laisse-le, c'est sa femme.
Carruthers.
C'est moi.
On a retrouvé l'institutrice.
- Ce qu'il en reste.
- Où es-tu ?
- Sur Main Street.
- Au nº 700 ?
Comment tu sais ?
J'arrive tout de suite.
Je ne comprends pas.
Ta femme...
Elle est morte.
Tu comprends ça ?
Elle s'automutilait.
Oui.
Tout va bien.
Elle est dans un monde meilleur.
Tout ira bien.
On est ensemble.
Voilà la première.
Là, la deuxième victime.
Voilà où l'histoire se termine.
- Elle ne s'échappera plus.
- C'était pas une prof.
C'était elle.
Arrêtez !
Qu'est-ce que vous faites ?
Je l'ai vu dans ses yeux.
Elle affirme que cette femme
grimpait sur les murs.
C'était elle.
On va lui faire une analyse de sang.
Va savoir avec quoi ils se shootent.
C'était elle, j'en suis sûre.
C'était Lizzie.
Je l'ai vu dans ses yeux.
Je sais pas comment elle a fait.
Arrêtez !
C'était Lizzie, c'était elle.
C'était si étrange.
Comme si je m'étais endormie
dans l'ambulance,
tandis que je te regardais.
Je ne voulais pas m'endormir,
mais j'étais si fatiguée.
Quand je me suis réveillée,
tu étais encore là.
T'es la première chose que j'ai vue.
Excusez-moi.
M. Galan, j'ai des papiers
à vous faire signer à l'accueil.
À tout à l'heure.
- On doit l'interner.
- Elle n'a pas tenté de se suicider.
J'étais là, c'était un accident.
C'était un accident.
Si vous mentez,
vous mettez sa vie en danger.
Vous lui avez parlé.
Elle semblait suicidaire ?
C'était un accident insolite,
rien d'autre.
Tout va bien ?
Tout va bien.
On rentre chez nous.
Je suis ta femme.
C'est notre maison ?
- Oui, elle n'est pas très grande.
- Elle est géniale.
Attends.
Je préfère comme ça.
Confrontation avec le mal.
Voyons.
Mon Dieu.
Marcus,
c'est mon âme qui est vierge,
pas mon corps.
Inutile d'être si prévenant.
- Vous disiez ne pas être flic.
- Je ne le suis pas.
Je l'ai été.
Ils ne me croient pas.
Ils me prennent pour une folle.
Je crois que tu dis la vérité.
Vraiment ?
Oui, je te crois.
Debout, paresseux.
Je t'ai épuisé hier soir ?
Il est quelle heure ?
Tu dois aller travailler,
alors prends ton petit-déjeuner.
- Tu vas faire quoi ?
- Traîner à la maison, j'imagine.
Je vais me doucher.
Tu peux me rejoindre.
Qu'est-ce que t'as ?
Je ne te plais plus ?
Elle était malade.
Elle avait le sida.
Moi et les autres filles,
on met toujours des capotes.
Toujours.
Pas Lizzie.
Si un de ses clients
essayait d'en mettre une,
alors elle l'excitait,
et elle lui retirait.
Elle courrait pas après leur fric.
Elle voulait leur refiler le sida.
Elle voulait les tuer.
M. Galan, je suis John Carruthers.
J'enquêtais sur l'affaire E. Markham.
Je suis devant chez vous.
Rappelez-moi, c'est important.
Fais gaffe, putain.
- Avance.
- Tu me gênes.
Merde.
- Monte.
- J'ai plus envie d'en parler.
Il ne s'agit pas de ça.
C'est pour quoi ?
Pour 50 $, tu fais quoi ?
Je ne suis pas si désespérée.
Et si je te donne 500 $ ?
500 $ ?
OK, grand-père.
Pour 500 $,
je te fais ce que tu veux.
Emma ?
Laisse-la passer.
Fais voir la marchandise.
Ça te plaît ?
Allez, vas-y.
Dépêche-toi.
Non.
Pas ce soir.
Tu veux quoi ?
Que tu t'allonges sur le canapé
et que tu dormes.
Et toi, tu vas faire quoi ?
Je vais m'asseoir et veiller sur toi.
Si quelqu'un vient te faire du mal,
je le tuerai.
Et mon fric ?
Tu auras ton argent.
Quand tout sera fini,
je te ferai quitter la ville.
T'as des enfants ?
J'avais un fils.
Avant.
T'étais où ?
Pardon ?
T'as quoi dans ce sac ?
C'est un cadeau pour toi.
Ça ne te regarde pas.
S ur charité se shoote à l'héroïne ?
- C'est pas de l'héroïne.
- Fais voir tes bras.
- Ne me touche pas.
- Fais voir.
Satisfait ?
Je veux Emma.
J'ai déjà essayé
de vivre comme une sainte.
Ça s'est mal terminé.
C'est pas ce que je veux.
Laisse-le-moi.
Salut.
Merci.
Tu devrais la voir, Jen.
Son regard.
C'est plus Carolina.
- Cette nana morte...
- Emma.
Emma.
Tu crois qu'elle est
dans le corps de Caro, c'est ça ?
Non.
Enfin, si.
Mais ce n'est pas Emma.
Je ne la connais pas.
T'as besoin d'aide.
Pourquoi là-bas ?
Pourquoi dans ce bâtiment occupé ?
Il y en a des tas.
Elle avait l'air
de bien connaître les lieux.
- C'est une histoire de fou.
- Je ne suis pas fou.
Je sais.
Je ne sais plus quoi faire.
Va voir Martineau.
Non, j'irai pas.
Il pourrait t'aider.
J'irai pas voir Martineau.
Pas ce soir.
Je ne veux pas rentrer chez moi.
Je veux que tu restes ici.
Merde.
La ferme, bordel de merde.
Non, ouste.
Klaus, sors de là.
Klaus, pousse-toi.
Bon chien.
- Martineau, salut.
- Ça fait un bail.
Tu vas trouver ça bizarre,
je vis une expérience surnaturelle.
- Va en parler à un curé.
- Non, attends.
Écoute, j'ai besoin d'aide.
- T'as été viré ?
- Hein ?
- Non.
Viens, rentre.
Allez.
Tourne-toi,
les mains contre le mur.
- Tu déconnes ?
- Fais ce que je te dis.
Bordel de merde.
- C'est une blague ?
- Non.
- Vous voulez vous payer ma gueule ?
- Non, je te promets.
C'est bon, t'es clean .
T'as un tas de chiens.
J'en ai sept.
C'est un chiffre important.
Métaphysiquement parlant.
Dans l'Égypte antique,
les chiens étaient vus
comme dotés d'un instinct divin.
En fait, les chiens,
de l'ensemble des animaux,
ce sont ceux qui repoussent
le plus aisément les esprits malins.
Ah ouais ?
J'en ai pas vu un seul.
Alors, euh...
À la centrale,
ils pensent encore que je suis fou ?
Ouais.
Je me demande pourquoi.
- T'as passé la nuit avec mon mari.
- Carla, écoute...
T'as dormi avec mon mari.
Tu me dois bien une tasse de café.
Si tu baises aussi mal
que tu fais du café,
j'ai pas à m'en faire.
Je n'ai pas couché avec ton mari.
Il avait besoin de parler.
Tu veux aller sentir mes draps ?
Je peux utiliser ton téléphone ?
Fais comme chez toi.
Pétasse.
Josie.
Où tu te caches, Josie ?
Tu devrais lire ce manuscrit.
Il coûte 25 $.
Ça couvre les frais de photocopie.
La seule boîte qui le publierait
est spécialisée en OVNIS
ou conneries de ce genre.
- La vie après la mort...
- Oui ?
- C'est effrayant ?
- Ça dépend.
Disons qu'en règle générale,
si t'as été sympa,
ta vie après la mort ressemblera
à un super week-end à Santa Barbara.
D'accord.
Si t'as été un enfoiré,
ça ressemblera plus
à un jeudi dans le New Jersey.
T'es obligé d'y aller ?
Imaginons que
je sois un vrai enfoiré
et que je sais ce qui m'attend.
- Je peux...
- Rester ici ?
Bien sûr, certains restent.
Les poltergeists passent leur temps
à déplacer des objets, etc.
Et revenir pour de vrai ?
Entrer dans quelqu'un d'autre.
Une possession permanente ?
C'est ça.
Allons parler ailleurs.
Pourquoi ?
Cette pièce est truffée de micros.
Josie.
Non !
Quand on parle de possession,
c'est en général des esprits anciens.
Des esprits qui n'ont jamais mérité
une naissance humaine.
Quelqu'un qui a vécu
peut rentrer dans un autre corps ?
C'est peu probable.
L'esprit possesseur
n'aurait pas assez de force
ou de savoir-faire
pour dominer son hôte.
- Pas au-delà de deux secondes.
- Si un hôte meurt,
son esprit doit quitter le corps.
Mais imagine qu'un secouriste
réussit à ranimer le corps.
- Un autre esprit pourrait...
- Entrer dans le corps vacant.
C'est possible ?
L'esprit qui sait faire ça
est un esprit vraiment très doué.
Si un corps se libérait,
un esprit bon n'entrerait pas.
Non.
- Il resterait à Santa Barbara.
- C'est ça.
Si un corps se libère
et qu'un esprit entre dedans...
Tu as un sérieux problème
sur les bras.
Comment je m'en débarrasse ?
M. Galan, vous êtes en danger.
Rappelez-moi.
C'est John Carruthers.
Il faut que tu découvres
pourquoi elle est là.
Si tu peux l'aider
à accomplir son dessein,
alors, peut-être qu'elle partira.
Et si, tout simplement,
elle ne tient pas à partir ?
Elle est plus forte.
Tu vas devoir
lui donner envie de partir.
Comment ?
C'est l'incarnation du mal.
Sois vertueux.
Quoi, je vais au catéchisme ?
C'est pas une mauvaise idée.
Oui ?
Je suis John Carruthers.
Marcus est là ?
Désolée, il est absent.
Je suis sa femme.
Enchanté de vous connaître.
Il ne devrait pas tarder.
Je vous invite
à l'attendre à l'intérieur.
Selon vous,
cette prostituée aurait possédé
le corps de l'institutrice.
Disons plutôt qu'elle l'aurait volé.
Les clés étaient sur le contact,
elle a sauté dedans
pour aller se faire une petite virée.
J'essaie une nouvelle recette.
Je n'arrive pas à trouver
exactement ce que je recherche.
Et maintenant,
la seconde femme est morte.
Elle est donc dans le corps
de quelqu'un d'autre.
Ça a l'air insensé.
Je ne suis pas fou, croyez-moi.
Mes grands-parents.
Ils pratiquaient la religion
des Pères fondateurs.
Vous voyez ?
Cette religion a marqué mon enfance.
Elle m'a terrifié.
Ma grand-mère parlait souvent
des "sauterelles".
Elle les appelait comme ça.
Des esprits qui changent de corps
quand ils sont usés.
Selon vous,
cette prostituée serait...
une "sauterelle" ?
Elizabeth Markham et l'institutrice
appartiennent à une lignée
d'une centaine de vies différentes.
Vous avez déjà entendu
parler de Lilith ?
Lilith ?
C'est une vieille légende.
Lilith était la femme d'Adam,
bien avant Ève.
Ça n'a pas marché entre eux,
Adam l'a rejetée.
Alors Dieu a créé Ève.
Ève a donc été la mère de l'humanité.
Mais Lilith était en colère.
C'est compréhensible.
Une fois morte,
elle a refusé de s'en aller.
Elle a juré de se venger
d'Adam, Ève et leurs enfants, nous.
Ce serait elle la responsable
des mort-nés et de la mort des bébés.
- On dit que c'est la mère des...
- "Sauterelles".
Oui, exactement.
J'ai un dessin.
Lilith.
Pas très flatteur comme dessin.
Non.
Tenez, goûtez.
C'est bon, très bon.
Il manque un petit truc.
Désolé, madame,
je ne suis pas un expert en cuisine.
Je ne dois pas être présentable.
- Vous êtes très bien.
- Vous dites ça pour être gentil.
Je vais me faire une beauté.
J'ai envie de continuer à parler
de votre théorie.
Ne bougez pas de là.
J'ai des balles en argent.
Je les ai faites tremper 7 min
dans de l'eau bénite.
Tire une balle en plein c ur.
Une autre dans la tête.
Tu plaisantes ?
Écoute, c'est pas un meurtre.
- Elle est dans le corps de...
- Ma femme.
Elle n'est plus de ce monde.
Je suis désolé.
- Tu crois que ça va marcher ?
- J'en sais rien.
C'est un territoire inconnu.
Si j'étais toi,
je tirerais, lui enfoncerais
un pieu dans le c ur,
je lui trancherais la tête
et je l'enterrerais.
À 30 mètres de profondeur.
Et je ferai poser une dalle en béton.
Pas de lune.
Madame, je dois absolument
parler à votre mari.
Madame ?
Dieu soit loué.
Tu es là.
La porte était fermée ?
Je ne me sentais pas en sécurité.
J'ai une surprise pour toi.
À qui est la voiture dehors ?
Je ne suis pas Carla.
Mais fais-moi confiance.
Je t'ai préparé à dîner, viens.
T'en dis quoi ?
C'est ma façon
de te demander pardon.
J'ai pas toujours été facile,
ces derniers temps.
Tout va rentrer dans l'ordre.
Assieds-toi,
j'ai une surprise pour toi.
- Yo, Shawn à l'appareil.
- C'est Marcus.
- T'es où ?
- De service, pourquoi ?
- Tu peux passer ?
- Ça va pas ?
J'ai besoin de parler.
Je crois que je perds...
Non, putain.
Marcus ?
Jenny.
Non.
J'ai vécu plus de vies
que tu ne peux l'imaginer.
En tant qu'hommes et femmes.
J'ai vécu partout
et à toutes les époques.
Tu ne peux rien m'apprendre.
Tu n'as aucune leçon à me donner.
Plus rien ne me surprend.
- Marcus.
- Non.
Jenny.
Viens assister au spectacle.
Je vais te faciliter la tâche.
Non.
Une de moins, plus que cinq.
Encore raté.
T'as déjà tiré avec un flingue ?
Il ne marche plus, c'est triste.
Encore
une
chance.
Bien...
joué.
Marcus.
Putain.
Jackson.
Je m'occupe de lui.
Allez, bats-toi.
Faut que tu t'en sortes.
- Aucune réponse.
- Allez Jenny, bats-toi.
Non...
Tout va bien.
Où est-il ?
Salut.
Regardez qui est debout.
Je vais vérifier votre tension.
Vous avez des choses à ajouter ?
C'est comme vous avez dit,
on avait une liaison.
Carla a essayé de nous tuer.
L'enfer n'est rien
comparé à une femme jalouse.
Vous devez avoir raison.
John était un très bon ami.
C'est difficile à croire
qu'une femme de 45 kg ait pu le tuer.
C'était pas une femme ordinaire.
Vous et moi, savons parfaitement
que ce rapport est incomplet,
tout n'a pas été dit.
Quand vous serez remis sur pied,
je vous paierai un verre
et vous m'en raconterez un peu plus.
Je ferme la porte ?
Non.
Laissez-la ouverte.
Tu as tiré.
On va faire un tour ?
C'est l'heure de se dire au revoir.
Tu sais,
tu ne pourras jamais me tuer.
Jamais pour de vrai.
Tu m'as tout pris.
Pas tout, non.
Peut-être qu'on se reverra un jour.
Hé !
Pourquoi tu restes sur terre ?
Ça te plaît tant que ça ?
Il y a pire, tu sais ?